das beste restaurant in meiner stadt das
ist ein unglaublicher titel wir sind
hier in köln einer millionenstadt und da
wirklich das beste von tausenden
restaurants zu sein ist unglaublich ich
habe in so vielen guten restaurants
gegessen hier in meiner heimatstadt köln
das das beste restaurant in meiner
starts ganz neue maßstäbe setzen muss
und ich sage mal so viel es war eine
überraschung war nämlich schon dort aber
was ihm vor wir natürlich nicht gemacht
habe ist bewertung anzuschauen und das
machen wir jetzt gemeinsam punkt 1 der
mich überrascht hat das ist ein
steakhouse das ok also wirklich das
beste restaurant nummer eins von 1901
restaurants in köln ist ein steakhouse
ich werde später wieder grundsätzlich
was to state häusern sagen meiner meines
erachtens nach das ist auf jeden fall
auch interessant sage ich mal was so
meine einstellung dazu ist aber fünf
sterne aus 118 bewertungen 112 von 118
bewertungen aus gezeigt das ist irre
drei sehr gut zwar in frieding eine
menge keine mit einem punkt das krass
bestes restaurant köstlich 1a service
essen und ambiente einfach überragend
top-qualität stakes auf den punkt ihr
merkt schon da muss wirklich einiges
stimmen und ob auch wirklich alles
stimmen weil ich meine das beste
restaurant in einer millionenstadt wie
köln ist ein unglaublicher titel
erinnert euch vielleicht wie wir bei
düsseldorf geflasht waren wir müssen uns
selbst überzeugen und wir sind
hingefallen so wir sind jetzt angekommen
leute und die erste sache die mir
wirklich direkt auffällt hört mein
man hört hier nichts wir sind zwar in
köln aber in rodenkirchen also ein
bisschen außerhalb und das finde ich
gerade über sky also als mensch der in
der innenstadt wohnt er dort die
restaurants besucht das immer laut immer
action wir sind hier direkt am rhein
hier drüben das ist erstmal schön also
die lage ist wirklich top eine davon ist
auch schon das restaurant und bin
gespannt also ich sage so viel ich war
ein bisschen kritisch im vorfeld aber es
ist schon geil weil hier das würde ich
schon geil aber auch das haus sieht
einfach schön aus so wie es das date
oder ochs royal zum offenen wintergarten
weil am rhein
ich war noch nie hier und ich mache ja
auch nicht gegangen war über schritt
weiter herzlich willkommen neben
augsburg also es ist wirklich schön
gemacht dass er mich verstehst also ja
irgendwie ein bisschen prunkvoll ja voll
aber nicht zu viel
eine grundsätzliche sache muss ich sagen
so steakhouse das ist voll nichts was
ich eigentlich machen würde das
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen warum
ich so ein bisschen kritisch eingestellt
bin weil ich finde das steak ist wenn du
mit becken hass und ein gasgrill das
einfachste was du machen kannst nicht
mal mit zu wied sondern du kannst
wirklich einfach dicke gewicht
temperatur zeit kannst du alles so
perfekt steuern das ist wirklich
vergleichsweise einfach und dafür im
restaurant da musste ich dann fängst du
perfekt science fällt auch direkt auf
das ist gehoben auch preislich behoben
also vorspeise durchschnitt über 15 euro
stakes klar sind teurer aber auch ihre
roben über 30 jetzt gerade nicht vor
wochen wie sollen wir vielleicht noch
eine empfehlung fragen und genau das
haben wir gemacht das resultat frisch
angegriffen die calamari und dazu das
original ockstadt habe das land
auch wieder hoch her was auch
aufgefallen ist unser kleiner das sehr
aufmerksam ich meine stadt mein medium
unternehmen mit johanna direkt
aufgeschrieben sondern also ist schon
cool
so entspannt hat ja
[Musik]
sagt auch schon so viel aus über das
brot finde ich wer sich mühe gibt brot
gibt es überall
[Musik]
wenn man so zwischen tisch bekommen was
es ist schon das hat so das regt einfach
den appetit nochmal so krass an die
weißt du musst glaube ich ganz ehrlich
gestehen ich habe nie qatar bestellt
hast du auch nicht deswegen wollte ich
ja ja ich will das hier probieren ich
sagte ehrlich die calamari sind glaube
ich krassen
also die calamari und knoblauch wir
probieren
hmm ich schon was abgeht sagt er ehrlich
das ist halt es ist nicht so dieses
verkomplizierte irgendwie weißt du das
ist einfach krass einfach eine wilde
quali es ist überhaupt nicht gummiartig
kein bisschen also ich sags ja wirklich
das catch auch so diesen maritimen weiß
ob es hat wirklich es hat auch was
maritimes hier drinnen irgendwie ich
weiß nicht aber nicht festmachen aber es
ist so jetzt mal dieses ganze knoblauch
öl mit geröstetem brot und grillten brot
dessen kopf einem nicht mehr sagt so
weiter das ist selbst für mich komisch
so nächste vorspeise unser ockstadt an
darauf bin ich jetzt auch sehr gespannt
ich bin vielleicht die falsche
reihenfolge dann eine ecke von unserem
theater
hätte beinahe so eine fruchtige süße
note und man sieht halt ist es super
frisch wenn man jemand so reingeht es
hat nichts mit grauem rand oder oxidiert
oder irgendwas das ist einfach super
fresh ist auch gar nicht so als würde
man was ein eigenartiges essen oder so
ist einfach lecker
ich würde auf jeden fall wieder
bestellen es einfach außerordentlich
sehr interessant sehr lecker und jetzt
kommen wir auch schon zum wahrscheinlich
entscheidenden heute mit dem steak dem
hauptgang wo bin ich hier warum bin ich
nicht mehr im restaurant warum habe ich
ein riesiges paket glaube das ist so
denn das heutige video wurde
freundlicherweise von motors unterstützt
die gibt es schon seit 2014 und sie
haben sich zur aufgabe gemacht das nicht
weiter unnötigerweise essen weggeworfen
wird damit ich mir ein bild davon machen
kann haben sie mir ein riesiges paket
zugeschickt mit einigen der produkten
die gerettet werden und es war wirklich
alles mögliche drin so ihr seht dass
jetzt gerade selbst werden dies auspacke
und ich war überrascht das ist auch
wirklich richtig coole sachen waren also
man tut nicht nur etwas gutes sondern
man hat auch irgendwelche limited
edition niemand so niemann probieren
würde und die produkte die von mutius
gerettet werden sind nicht irgendwie
schlecht oder so sondern gründe dafür
dass produkte bei motors landen sind
überproduktion fehldrucke oder auch
falsche verpackungen
was ich wirklich stark findet seit april
2020 hat mozart uns über 6 millionen
kilogramm lebensmittel gerettet und ich
meine ich habe mich selbst überzeugt ich
habe die sachen probiert getestet die
sind super also diesen einwandfrei man
könnte wirklich keinen unterschied
feststellen zu denen die man im
supermarkt kauft und wenn man sich
einfach mal vor augen führt dass ein
drittel aller lebensmittel im müll
landen ist es wirklich eine sinnvolle
idee zu gucken ob man sachen die man
sowieso kaufen würde nicht vielleicht
gerettet kaufen kann einfach damit nicht
weitere lebensmittel im müll land was
ich ebenfalls cool finde motors bietet
auch direkt rezept an die man mit den
sachen kochen kann dementsprechend
wirklich ein cooles angebot absolut
übrigens kennt den code max ab 15
prozent sparen auf eure bestellung wieso
flüstere ich keine ahnung check-in gott
marx ab lasst euch schmecken
vielen dank also ich finde es hin die
jetzt fast ein bisschen richtung wer
aber es ist für mich jetzt überhaupt
keinen druck also ich bin vor allem
darauf gespannt die schmeckt das beste
restaurant meiner stadt komme ich da
hinten los für mich für mein geschmack
ist es auch super aber wir sind hier
bestens order statt und wenn man mir
bestellt dafür ist es ein bisschen
proben aber bei gutem fleisch bei guter
qualität von fleisch ist das natürlich
auch vollkommen im rahmen natürlich das
geht vollkommen gleich während avatar
gegessen wurde aber es ist halt einfach
so
frage von solches sei ich probiere das
rechtlich auch beste steak in meiner
stadt also ich schreibe ja lavastein
will das merkt man wirklich da ist so
richtig dicke große play war auch
wahnsinnig viel rabatt angemerkt dass
mistress für mein verständnis übrigens
direkt immer drauf packen eure kartoffel
hat er auch schon richtig ins zeug ja
super lecker wird der spagat zwischen
dieser kruste und die sind gut erinnere
ist schon besonders also da muss ich
auch sagen das habe ich so auch selbst
und nicht entwicklung so dieses zarte
innere ja aber diese kruste deshalb
wirklich besonders
bei lang super gab sich in portionen
auch von dem man wirklich satt wird auch
mit mitteln mit hunger
bahn also wirklich sehr sehr guter
service auffallend guter service zudem
muss man wirklich hervorheben werden was
nimmt man da ist die frage ist es auch
glaube ich einfach zu schwer übers herz
zu trinken etwas das beste zu nennen ja
ja und das ding ist halt wir haben auch
in den videos so viele gute restaurants
erlebte wirklich top restaurants ich
musste zum beispiel als ich muss andere
caruso passt aber denken ja ich muss das
boxplay denkt schon schweres geschütz
das beste das ist so rich matti das zu
unterstreichen ist schon hart ja ich
würde aber wahrscheinlich wir
unterstreichen dass es vom gesamtpaket
das beste steak restaurant in dem ich
war auf jeden fall aber kommando es gibt
tage da bist du am liebsten der
ex-kicker damit so gar nicht passt da
finden wir das was man bekommen dass der
preis auch absolut gerecht werden so
service ambiente ist der wirklich ein
schickes ambiente sehr alters her
dann essen also das ist auf jeden fall
dass etwas höhere preis wenn du
vollkommen mehr abstreiten gehe ich mit
dem film fällt das finde ich nämlich
auch das hat man finde ich gemerkt ab
dem moment mobil draußen waren sind wir
angekommen sind dass es so ein
restaurant zum essen gehen ist dass sich
auch so anfühlt und ihm essen gehen
essen gehen das ist und das ist um so
einen moment das ist nicht so besitzen
die moralischen und entscheiden spontan
heute abend in minsk sondern das steht
schon heute für nicht genau so ein ding
ist das auch wenn es zu spontanen ginge
es ist halt ein happening gefährt
draußen ja du hast ambiente du hast
einen kellner der auch entsprechend
gekleidet ist und so weiter es ist schon
besonders auf jeden fall also leute ich
war wirklich selten so sagt was sich
sehr für reisen im restaurant es war ein
toller aufenthalt aber wie toll das sage
ich euch jetzt dass ochs royal ist das
angeblich beste restaurant in köln die
ruhigeren lage begünstigt diese tatsache
aber um die nummer eins aus tausenden
restaurants in köln zu sein muss
wirklich alles passen
der service außergewöhnlich gut die
portion großzügig die qualität der ist
keine wünsche offen einzig und allein
der garten meines fleisch war nicht
perfekt getroffen was aber auf meinen
wunsch sofort geändert worden wäre mein
fazit das aus real ist sehr gut mit
sicherheit hat es auch eine bewertung
mit fünf von fünf sternen verdient ist
es aber die abgeschlagene spitze
keinesfalls es ist jedoch mit sicherheit
insbesondere in seiner kategorie eines
der besten restaurants in köln und einen
besuch werden also die haben eine
bewertung gehört es ist unglaublich gut
es ist das beste steak aus nämlich je
war aber es ist halt einfach nicht mit
abstand über allen anderen nummer eins
deshalb verstehe ich auch dass da immer
eine dynamik drin ist das mal das
festnetz anschlüssen viele von den guten
straßen den wir waren rangieren auch in
diesen oberen plätzen es war ein
erlebnis ist war geil danke dass ihr
dabei waren danke dass du diese videos
möglich macht wir sind zwar nächsten
video wieder macht's gut